Hier ist der Erste Deutsche Podcast mit den Dino-News. Heute für Sie im Studio Florentin Will und Stefan Tietzler. Pangea, die ersten Dinosaurier betreten die Bühne der Welt.
Ja, schönen guten Tag zur Pressekonferenz des ersten deutschen Dinosaurierkongresses.
Mein Name ist Archeoptrix, ich buchstabiere.
A-R-
Sie müssen nicht buchstabieren.
Sehr gut, ähm Gibt es Fragen? Ja, einmal vom archäologischen Abendblatt. Warum sind die nur so cool? Weil wir haben, trotz unserer Federn, unseres Quarkens, den Crocs an unseren Füssen und diesem bunten Federkleid. Toller, manche sagen coole Eigenschaften, wie zum Beispiel krasses Gebiss, wir jagen, nicht alle, bei weitem nicht alle, aber wir jagen. Viele sind recht gross, ja. Werner Friebel vom Dino-Dienstag. Was sagen Sie zu den Gerüchten, dass Sie bald aussterben?
Erstmal, großer Fan, gar kein Fan vom Dino-Donnerstag.
Und dann höre ich Sie an, Herr Mösler, weil Sie wirklich einfach das Klatschpresse.
Das sind Lügen, Dino-Donnerstag ist nicht, wirklich nicht.
Wir decken Wahrheiten auf.
So, was war die Frage, Dino-Dienstag?
Es gibt Gerüchte, dass Sie bald aussterben.
Was sagen Sie dazu?
Das ist Unsinn. Wie soll das denn passieren? ähn, wo, also, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, dazu? Das ist Unsinn. Wie soll das denn passieren? Woran, wo, wie, also, das sind Verschwörungstheorien. Naja, es gibt ja diesen riesigen, der menschengemachte, ach so. Es gibt ja diesen riesigen Felsen am Himmel, der langsam, aber sicher näher rast. Mhm. Mond meinen sie jetzt. Nee, den anderen. Wissen Sie, das ziehe mich nicht so richtig
für...
Ihr hört das Podcast-Ufo
mit Stefan
und Flori.
Tietze,
Stefan Tietze, vielen Dank
an dieses herrliche Intro von
Orkan und Malte,
die hier perfekt harmoniert
haben. Ich finde das ja immer toll, wenn man so in Harmonie, so Barbershop-mässig singen kann.
Ich finde das ja grossartig.
Ich höre es mir für ein paar, es ist so dieses Stomp-Phänomen, so das ist, man denkt sich, ach geil, die können richtig gut Musik machen, aber ich würde mir keine Show anschauen.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich so ein Barbershop-Quadett mir ein ganzes Lied anhöre, aber wenn man so ein ganzes Lied anhört. Aber wenn man so Seid zur Freund, schafft bereit, wir sind Freunde für alle Zeit, für alle Zeit. Toll. Im Dschungelbuch für ein kurzes Lied, das ja dann durch Dialog unterbrochen wird. Gott sei Dank, im kleinen Snackable-Happen unterteilt. Ansonsten komme ich da nicht durch, muss ich sagen. Da mag ich das gern. Ich finde das immer toll, wenn Leute das können. Barbershop-Quartett, ja eine Kunstform, die eine kurze Zeit, kurzlebige Zeit hatte, immer noch religi-mässig dabei ist, aber nicht mehr so wirklich oft. Nee, ich finde, ja, schon auch weird ein bisschen. Auch so wahrscheinlich ein Begriff, wo denn der Ursprung völlig verloren gegangen ist. Warum Barbershop-Quartett? Was hat das mit dem Friseur zu tun? Was ist da los? Aber ich will es gar nicht wissen, weil ich geniesse die Harmonien. Und ich mag immer, dass immer der, der am tiefsten singt, ist immer so der, der unscheinbarste. Könnte ich dir ein Bild von einem Barbershop-Quartett zeigen? Und du zeigst mir den Sänger, der Sänger der Bass. Lass uns das unnötig lange besprechen jetzt.
Okay, hier geht es mal bitte alle auf www.google.com und da könnt ihr.
Barbershop-Quartett.
Warte mal, warte mal.
So, und zwar.
Hier, wir nehmen mal den Wikipedia-Eintrag von Barbershop-Quartett. Die sehen alle ein bisschen aus wie du. Und das ist das Navy-Quartett. Vier Leute, könnt ihr alle jetzt mitspielen, das Spiel? Könnt ihr alle jetzt schnell mal euer Handy raussuchen auf der Wikipedia-Seite von Barbershop-Quartett, also en.wikipedia.org slash wiki slash barbershop unterstrich quartett raute slash media slash file doppelpunkt us unterstrich navy unterstrich 080615 minus n minus 7656 r minus 003. Wir reden von denen jetzt. Das sind die Power Ranger. Ah, so. Stefan, das sind die Power Ranger. Geh doch einfach auf den US-Wikipedia-Artikel vom Barbershop-Quartett. Finde ich doch. Und da The US Navy Band Northwest Barbershop-Quartett. So, und da können wir jetzt sagen, wer singt hier die tiefste Stimme von diesen sehr ähnlich aussehenden Menschen, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen. Es sind immer die, die am angestrengtesten gucken. Ich glaube, es ist der dritte von links. Der dritte von links, exakt. Ja, okay, gut. Nur ein Freund für alle Zeit, für alle Zeit. Ja, das war unsere neue Rubrik. Wer singt am höchsten? Ich würde sagen, der ganze Linke. Das ist unsere neue Rubrik Barbershop
Chaos. Wer singt am tiefsten?
Wer singt denn jetzt am tiefsten?
Die Barbershop Challenge. Die Barbershop Chaos
Challenge mit Guido Kanz,
präsentiert von Guido Kanz.
Gibt's den noch? Gibt's den noch, Guido?
Guido Kanz lebt und macht vieles.
Guido Kanz kriegt so viele Ideen auf dem Teller,
dass er da gar nicht mithalten kann. Können wir
die Verschwörungstheorie und ich finde, Guido Kanz wäre nicht das viele Ideen auf dem Teller, dass er da gar nicht mithalten kann. Können wir die Verschwörungstheorie, und Guido Kanz wäre nicht das schlechteste Ziel für diese Idee, in die Welt setzen, dass sich ein deutscher Promi hat einfrieren lassen und deswegen nicht mehr da ist? Aber er ist jederzeit bereit, wieder aufgetaut zu werden. Also man könnte, weil das Problem ist ja, du musst die Verschwörungstheorie ja wasserdich bauen, dass es keine Beweise dagegen geben kann, sondern dass wenn die Person irgendwann auftaucht, sagst du, ah, die ist aber kaum gealtert, die war eingefroren. Lasst uns, also wir wollen erreichen, dass wenn man bei Google Guido Kanz eingibt, das nächste Wort eingefroren ist. Einfrier, äh, was denn da steht, Kontroverse. Oder so Kryptonit, nee, wie heisst das, Carbonit, Carbonit, aber wie stellst du das dir vor, eingefroren, also ist er in so einem Eisblock, wie so einem Mammut, oder in Carbonit, wie Han Solo?
Man sagt es ja über Walt Disney, dass er sich hat einfrieren lassen, um irgendwann in der Zukunft, wenn man dann Menschen wieder auftauchen kann und die sozusagen immer noch funktionieren als Menschen leben, kann man auch sagen, dass sie dann aufgetaut werden. Und das ist ja, ich weiß nicht, ob es so ein Urban Myth ist oder sowas. Naja, der Urban Myth geht ja noch weiter, und zwar, dass extra der Film Frozen produziert wurde, dass wenn man Walt Disney Frozen googelt, man auf den Film kommt und nicht darauf, dass Walt Disney eingefroren wurde, weil man anscheinend will, dass das geheim bleibt, damit nicht irgendjemand sagt, wir tauen den mal auf. Welche Filme wurden noch gemacht, um Dinge zu verschleiern? Was war denn For Frozen? Shrek, Coco. Es gab eine Kokosnussverschwörung, dass da Spinnen drin leben in diesen Kokosnissen. Und dann wurde es von Walt Disney, es kann gut sein.
Filme sind ja oft einfach völlig willkürlich
benannt. Pineapple Express,
komplett Bullshit,
wie Grand Budapest Hotel,
einfach willkürliche Worte aneinander
gehängt, die gar keinen Sinn haben.
Es gibt keinen im Film, Riesenentäuschung,
der sagt, ich bin es Grand Budapest,
mein Name ist Grand Budapest Hotel.
Ja, null. Riesenentäuschung, ich bin schon wirklich vor Ende rausgegangen. Und dann kannst du doch ja deinen Film nutzen, um von einem Thema abzulenken oder auf ein Thema hinzuweisen. Dass du einfach sagst, es ist ein Action-Thriller und der heisst Climate Crisis, so dass die Leute das guckt, na wohl, dann würden die ja auf den Film kommen. Human-Made Climate Crisis is a real thing.
Kannst du nicht
deinen nächsten Film so nennen?
Deine witzige Rom-Com mit
Sci-Fi-Elementen, irgendwie, ja,
jeder hat jetzt eine Partner auf der
App, die Menschen lernen sich
gar nicht mehr kennen, weil jeder hat noch so hörmässig
so eine App,
Partner, Pepner,
und wie heißt der Film? Der Sozialstaat stirbt. Wer zu viel den Sozialstaat aushöhlt, der macht die marode, das marode Fundament unserer Gesellschaft noch weiter hinlänglich kaputt. So heißt der Film und es geht im Kern darum, dass Pepner die App, wo du deinen Partner hast, dass jeder hat dann sozusagen, weil es ist einfacher irgendwie, man hat gar keine Beziehungen mit anderen Leuten und dann geht aber bei jemandem die App kaputt, das Update funktioniert nicht, kann die App nicht mehr öffnen. Ja, und dann geht er zum Kundensupport und da lernt er Jennifer kennen und Jennifer ist der Kundensupport und dann verliebt er sich in Jennifer und dann ist aber die Pappnerin eifersüchtig. Jennifer, Jennifer, am Kundendesk ist immer da für mich, ist immer da, Jennifer. Und dann frag und dann fragt die partnerin fragt dann ja hey
ich habe gesehen in deinen nachrichten weil die hat komplette kontrolle dass du mir dieser
jennifer schreibst was magst du denn an jennifer und dann piano ich weiß gar, wo ich anfangen soll, ihre Haare, ihr Humor, ihr Geschmack und ihr Tenor. Der ist nicht so gut ausgefeilt, der Teil des Films, aber danach wird es richtig gut. Wichtig, es geht nur um den Titel, es geht nur um den Titel der marode sozialstaat wird ausgebildet aus die grundlagen unserer gesellschaft aus geballert auf damit ja das stimmt schon ich weiß auch nicht froze also genau deswegen finde ich die idee wie du kannst gefroren aber wie kriegen wir das jetzt in die medien also wie kriegen wir das jetzt ein das ist eine falschm das ist eine Falschmeldung, eine Ente, wir planten die. Wir planten die. Als grosse satirische Metapher, ja wogegen, ja wissen wir nicht, ja wofür, ja keine Ahnung, ja was verändern wir damit, ja nichts, das ist lustig. Ja wir machen es erstmal, die Interpretation, die Intellektuellen können ja später interpretieren, das müssen wir ja nicht machen. Ja lass Widerboden danach viel Zeit schreiben, was wir da gemacht haben. Hören wir danach nochmal, wenn wir gucken, wie es ankommt oder was die Leute sagen. Guido Kanz eingefroren. Ja, also erstmal müssen wir das Gerücht in die Welt streuen, Guido Kanz altert nicht, weil er immer nur für Auftritte aufgetaut wird und danach wieder eingefroren wird. Und das müssen wir erstmal etablieren und dann, wenn er lange abwesend ist, können wir sagen, Moment, ist er jetzt wirklich für gut eingefroren? Dauerhaft? Für immer? Für gut. Ist er für gut? Und dann ist die grosse Suche. Wo ist Guido? Wo ist Guido, wo kann er nur sein? Ich weiss es noch nicht, aber irgendwo wird er doch sein. Wo ist Guido, ich such ihn links und rechts, egal wo er ist, ja wir finden ihn geschwind. Wo ist Guido, wo ist Guido, wo ist Guido? Und dann suchen, Deutschland sucht Guido Kanz. Deutschland sucht ihn und findet ihn in der Küche. In der Küche. In der Küche Schrank. Und die Koordinaten waren dann doch die ganze Zeit die Telefonnummer von Glas oder sowas. Ja, aber ist es eine Möglichkeit, Leute einzufrieren, also auch gegen ihren Willen zu sagen, du bist vor deiner Zeit, lass uns dich noch mal einfrieren, in 100, 200 Jahren bist du bereit? Wäre es nicht eine Idee, weil so Wiedereingliederungsmassnahmen in die Gesellschaft bei Inhaftierten funktionieren ja bei uns okay, auch nicht richtig perfekt, keine Ahnung, ich weiß ja wenig drüber, ehrlich gesagt, und wollte mich rausprobieren.
Ich habe da aktuell keine
meinungsstarke Doku drüber gesehen, deswegen bin ich
da leer, blank. Genau, richtig, und deswegen
bin ich da komplett blank, aber
wäre es nicht eine Idee, alle Inhaftierten
einzufrieren,
um sie wieder aufzufrieren,
also man macht diesen Test an Straftätern,
die ihr Leben eh verwirkt
haben, weil das, weil sie
so eine krasse Strafe bekommen haben, dass sie eh ihr
Die Also man macht diesen Test an Straftätern, die ihr Leben eh verwirrt haben, weil sie so eine krasse Strafe bekommen haben, dass sie eh ihr lebenslang raus wären. Die friert man ein. An wem soll man sonst testen? Ach so, eh. Und dann friert man sie auf, wenn es wieder geht. Und das ist ja auch eine Zeit, wo man... Ich dachte, wenn das Verbrechen nicht mehr strafbar ist. Ah, super! So, weil dann, es verändert sich ja, und früher waren irgendwie noch ganz merkwürdige Sachen strafbar, die heute nicht mehr strafbar sind. Und dann friert man sie so lange ein, bis die Gesellschaft weit genug ist, bis was auch immer sie getan haben, irgendwie Datenschutz, Raub oder irgendwie sowas, nicht mehr strafbar ist. Und dann werden sie entlassen und aufgetraut. Ist doch viel geiler einfach, man sitzt nicht mehr im Knast, sondern man wird eingefroren, bis die Strafe vorbei ist. Ja, also wenn du wirklich reich bist, also angenommen Donald Trump kommt jetzt ins Gefängnis, zehn Jahre Hochverrat, könnte der einfach sagen, ja, dann lasse ich mich einfrieren. Udo Lindenberg war so klar. Ich habe das beste Eis. Ich habe das beste Eis. Trump auf Deutsch ist gar nicht so leid. Ich habe das beste Eis. Super, super. Du legst nämlich selber ein Ei auf. Ich friere mich ein und dann komme ich zurück. Ich werde besser sein. Ich habe das beste Eis. Es ist riesig, es ist riesig. Biden hat kein Eis. Ich habe Eis. Beste Eis. Ich gehe in den besten Knast. Ich gehe in den Knast und es ist der beste Knast. Deutschland, Merkel, Flüchtlingskrise hat es übermannt das Land, die Deals mit Deutschland, aber ich habe den besten Knast, weil er immer so unzusammenhängig spricht. Ach so, okay. China! Aber finde ich eine gute Idee. Da könnte man dem Rechtsstaat wirklich ein Schnippchen schlagen, wenn man einfach sagt, was sagt ihr, zwölf Jahre, gut, bing, bing, bing, tsch, bing, tsch, bing, tsch, bing, tsch, ganz langsam steigt das Wasser und man sagt so, tschüss, recht statt, tschau, tschau, und in einer halben Stunde steigt das Wasser langsam. Geht das denn? Geht. Hat sich. Man kann Insekten einfrieren, die leben dann wieder, man kann Ratten einfrieren, die leben dann wieder, Pflanzen, glaube ich, kann man auch einfrieren. Der Mensch ist ein Mysterium. Ich denke immer, er ist erst World Disney. World Disney? Ja, ich denke immer Disney World, World Disney. Ach so, okay. Und jetzt habe ich als Kind schon gedacht, dass er World... Ah, der World Disney, der Disney World. Ich habe es immer falsch verstanden, Walt Disney, World Disney. Ach so. Und es es immer noch falsch ein. Also kurz aus dem Tod kursierten Gerüchte durch die Klatschspalten, dass der Filmemacher seinen Körper einfrieren liess durch Kryotechnik. Doch diese urbane Legende ist nicht wahr. Disney wurde nach seinem Tod eingeäschert und ins Weltall geschossen. Das Gegenteil wäre eine coolere Theorie.
Ne, genau das Gegenteil, statt eingefroren verbrannt. Das ist ja mal eine Plottwist.
Aber es gibt, ich habe mal eine Doku gesehen, es gibt tatsächlich diese Kryofirmen, die einen für viel, viel Geld einfrieren.
Und das ist ja schon ein krasses Versprechen, weil man ja sagt, hey, wir frieren euch ein und wir lassen den Strom an, vielleicht die nächsten hunderttausend Jahre. Also welche Firma der Welt kann denn so ein Versprechen leisten, zu sagen, du gibst uns jetzt eine Million Euro, dafür frieren wir deine Leiche ein und dann lassen wir das Licht an. Erstmal kostet es ja viel mehr als Millionen Euro und das ist ja sehr viel Geld, ich finde es eine geniale Idee.
Als Geschäftsmodell. Wäre es doch nicht verklagen, wenn es nicht klappt.
Ja eben.
Also kommen dann die Familienangehörigen.
Machen wir den Stecker jetzt raus.
Jeffrey, mach mal den Stecker da raus.
Hä, was? Nein.
Machen wir den Stecker raus jetzt.
Hä, da ist Guido Kanz, hier ist Guido Kanz eingefroren.
Wir brauchen den Guido Kanz. Hier hat gerade ein sehr reicher, braucht jetzt Platz, wir haben keinen Platz mehr.
Moment, aber was ist denn, wenn in 200 Jahren jetzt die Technik erfunden wird, dass Guido Kanz wieder zum Leben entdeckt werden kann? Und was soll er dann machen, wenn er jetzt stirbt, wenn wir jetzt einen Stecker ziehen? Sollen wir uns dann verklagen? Nee, er hat seit hunderten von Jahren keine Familie mehr, niemand wird wissen, dass er hier einfach auftaut wie so eine alte Spinat. Zieh jetzt Stecker bei Guido Kanz raus. Der, der, der taut auf wie eine ähmliche Erbse.
Ist es dann auch einfach ein Stecker?
Ich glaube, im Grunde ist es alles ein Stecker. Im Kern ist alles ein Stecker.
Im Kern ist alles ein Stecker.
Das denke ich mir auch bei so Konzerten immer, wo so Lengcess Arena ist voll, Lightshows und dann so riesige Boxentürme und dann noch diese Halbkreise, die so von oben alles beschallen, alles wird beschallt, am Ende hängt alles an Steckdose, denke ich mir. Einer ist in der Steckdose und wenn Limpis da irgendwie nochmal zur Kaffeemaschine geht und aus Versehen stolpert, zack, ist alles aus. Man muss daran denken, wenn man irgendwie dann auch so nervös, ich bin manchmal so nervös bei so Massensachen oder sowas, das ist alles Steckdose. Wann bist du nervös? Ja, meistens bei so Massensachen. Ja, so Massenevents, Massensattraktionen. Ja, wenn du wieder die Massen angezogen hast, willst du sagen. Nein, so bei so einem Konzert. Und dann muss man sich eigentlich überlegen, nein, nein, nein, das sind nur MP3s und Steckdosen. Okay, es ist alles nur Elektronen. Im Kern sind es MP3s, der Keyboarder spielt, macht MIDI, der hat ein MIDI-Programm, ein Logic. Das hängt mir auch manchmal mit Angst vor Slipknot und so, weil die ja so gruselig aussehen. Hast du auch Angst vor Slipknot? Ja, aber warum gehst du denen dann aufs Konzert? Ich habe eigentlich ganz so Angst vor denen. Doch, manchmal muss man ja auch sich konfrontieren mit denen. Seinen engsten Stellen, ja klar. Okay, man hat mir gesagt, ich soll mich mit meiner grössten Angst stellen, Slipknot. Das war Slipknot. Ja, weil die so gruselig aussehen und weil die Musik mir Angst macht. Dann geht man hin, dann muss ich mir mal einreden, es sind nur Midi. Der hat Midi, ist im Kern Midi. Und die haben Kopfhörer im Ohr von Ultimate Ears. Und das ist jetzt gerade Fistur. Es ist Fistur und dann B und dann Crescendo. Es ist A-Moll, der Song ist in A-Moll. Und es nimmt zu dem krassen Death Metal, ja logisch, das steht vorne schon mit dran. Ja, aber es ist halt trotzdem A-Moll, mein gutes altes A-Moll. Es beruhigt einen schon so ein bisschen. Aber er hat eine Fender-Gitarre, er hat eine Gitarre, er spielt im Kern Gitarre. Er spielt Gitarre, nur dass er diesen Fußschemel nicht hat. Wie ich damals, wie ich mit meinem Fußschemel und den langen Fingernägeln spielt der Typ Gitarre. Vielleicht hat er sich verspielt gerade. Ich weiß es nicht. Und dann hat er gerade seine Saiten gestimmt, weil die verstimmt sind? Im Prinzip ist es ein Gitarrenvorspiel. Ich weiss ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht, was Slipknot für Musik macht. Wir hören kurz rein. Nein! Nein, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht, bitte nicht sie... Dann müssen sie das Plektrum so in den Mund stecken. Dann müssen sie eine Saite noch nicht aufziehen. Äh, Jonathan? Jonathan, kommst du rasch mal? Ja, Michael. Jonathan, kommst du mit dem Hebel? Ja, Michael Bernhard. Kommst du ja mit dem Hebel, mir ist die D-Seite gerissen.
Ach, was war nochmal die G-Seite?
Ach, dein Mund ist ganz ...
Geh du alter Esel, hol Fisch.
Ein alter Dackel ging Honig essen.
Ja.
Das war der Merksatz.
Geh du ...
Alter Esel, das ist aber der Quintenzirkel.
Ah, ja, stimmt. Das ist Geh du alter Esel, hol Fische und frische Brezen essen Asse des Gesangs. Ui, ui, keine Ahnung was es bedeutet, aber die Eselsbrücke ist noch steht, steht noch. Aber du könntest immer die Quinte hochgehen. Wie baut man eine Brücke? Weil, ich mein, sorry, ich mein, sorry, ich mein, sorry, ich mein, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, der, mein, man nähert sich, aber wie, weil das, was erhält, muss er ins, also baut man ersten Mast ins Wasser und dann legt man ein Brett drüber oder wirft man erst ein Seil oder hat man auf beiden Seiten Leute, also müssen die einen Umweg nehmen oder gibt es ein Boot, ist ein Boot involviert, das irgendwas hält nach oben oder so. Du redest jetzt von reisenden Flüssen, nur mal fürs Beispiel. Ich rede vom Rhein, ich rede vom Rhein, das sind richtig grosse Brücke, also es sind erstmal Schiffe, Hängebrücke. Hängebrücke. Eine ganz grosse Planke und dann stellt man die auf der einen Seite um auf und dann kippt man es um und dann hat man schon mal so und dann der Rest ist ja easy. Moment, aber die hält, wenn man da drüber läuft, über den Rhein? Nein, nein, nein, das ist nur zu konstruieren jetzt. Ach so. Das ist nur zu konstruieren. Okay. Man stellt quasi eine riesen Planke auf, kippt die um über den Rhein und jetzt kann man da natürlich drauf irgendwie Beton gießen und dann nimmt man die weg irgendwann.
Weißt du? Aber wie kriegt man so eine lange Planke? Also das ist ja wie eine riesige hohe Planke. Plankenbauer. Plankenbauer. Das ist eine deutsche Firma lustigerweise im Rheinhessen-Gebiet. Riesige Planken. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich glaube, da sind Boote involviert und Taucher,
die erstmal was hochhalten und dann stützen die das
und dann wird das oben eingesteckt. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Es war ja mal so, dass die Kölner
Seilbahn, da gibt es ja diese
Seilbahngondeln über den Rhein
und die sind immer stehen geblieben.
Und dann war eine Familie direkt mit ihrer Gondel über dem Rhein und diese Gondel hat sich auch irgendwie verkeilt und so und da mussten die halt gerettet werden, die waren schon vier Stunden da drin ho, war es dann Sonntag aber auch cool irgendwie auch ein cooles Abenteuer und dann kam ein vom, weil die waren halt überm Rhein dann kam ein Rheinschiff mit einem riesen Kran. Das heisst, diese Tische vergibt's. Ja. Und dann kam das, und dann dachte ich mir auch so, unmöglich kannst du doch so gut navigieren, dass das Schiff auf dem Rhein immer die gleiche Position hält. Ja, das ist spannend. Aber anscheinend geht's, und dann haben die einen grossen Kran gehabt und dann haben die Familie gerettet vom Rhein. Das ist ja, also diese Rheinseilbahn, die habe ich schon so oft gesehen und die war immer ein Mysterium. Und dann habe ich letztens noch mal gesehen, Conan O'Brien in Deutschland. Ja, fährt einfach damit. Und fährt mit dieser Rheinseilbahn und denkt, so das ist es, das ist das Bild, das Conan O'Brien hat von deutscher Kultur, dass diese Rheinseilbahn, das war für mich so merkwürdig, das ist genau diese Leerstelle für mich. Ich mag das Video gar nicht. Ich mag das Video gar nicht, wie er hier ist.
Doch, ich finde das, also
ich fand das schon lustig. Ich kann da laut
lachen, ja. Ja, bei Colin O'Brien auch,
aber ich mag gar nicht, ich mag gar nicht
wie Harald Schmidt und so,
das alles irgendwie so ein bisschen piechig.
Ja, aber das ist, ja, aber das
dafür mag ich es auch ein bisschen. Keiner spricht Englisch,
irgendwie diese wahnsinnigen Missverständnisse,
dann diese ganzen Deutschland-Klischees, ich finde das alles sehr unangenehm zu gucken. Die wahnsinnigen Missverständnisse, ja, das stimmt schon. Die waghalsigen Missverständnisse. Aber noch mal ganz kurz, weil wenn du sagst, man baut eine lange Planke und wirft die dann um, warum baut man nicht einfach die Brücke komplett erst in die Lühe, wie ein Hochhaus und wirft und lässt dann die komplette Brücke einfach fallen.
Weil du kannst ja ein Hochhaus
bauen. Wenn du es unten anbaust, nach oben,
kein Problem, kennen wir. Nee, das denken
viele. In Wahrheit baut man von oben nach unten.
Ach so. Man baut halt auch quasi
große Planken, so, und dann
sind die das Gerüst und dann baut man von oben runter
und dann nimmt man die Planken weg. Kann es sein, dass dein
gesamtes Weltbild nur auf Planken basiert?
Ja. Dass alles mit Planken zu erklären ist. Ich meine, wir sind eigentlich, Papa, du hast doch letztens erzählt. Komm mal her, Hendrik, setz dich. Papa, du hast doch gesagt, dass, als wir nachts in den Himmel geguckt haben, hast du doch gesagt, dass schon mal Menschen auf dem Mond waren. Ja, genau. Wie sind die Menschen denn auf den Mond gekommen? Das war eine Sache. Aber die Deutschen waren beteiligt. In Rheinhessen nämlich gibt es die grösste Plankenfirma, eine grosse Planke. Und die wurde gebaut, die muss man sich vorstellen, weil die Erde ist ja, da bin ich mir sicher, eine Kugel. Ja. Und die Planke war so gross, dass sie genau in der Mitte liegen musste, weil die Strecke, die die Planke zurücklegen musste zum Mond. Das Kilometer, wie die Planken passen dazwischen, normalerweise, eine normale Planke, weiss ich jetzt auch nicht. Und diese Planke, die zum Mond geht, hat man hier auf der Erde gebaut, eine große Planke. Und die musste genau so austariert werden, dass die Mitte auf der Erde ist, weil sonst wäre es von der Erde gekippt. Verste du das ganz keine augen von der erde werf mal wieder wach du schläfst wieso ein das nur eine frage gestellt ja das gefühl du fragst mich fragen um danach besser schlafen zu können nur ich wollte dass ich die geschichte vorlesen um schlafen zu können ist gemein ist gemein und blöd tut mir leid papa so und Planke, wurde dann aufgerichtet, da waren sehr viele Männer von Nöten, Manneskraft von Nöten damals. Und dann wurde sie gegen, hallo, wach auf! Und dann wurde sie gegen den Mond. Sie stand so spät, Papa. Dann wurde sie gegen, dann muss man genau abzielen, dass man sie im richtigen Moment loslässt, weil die Planke ist ca. 45 Minuten gekippt, weil die so gross war. Und der Mond musste genau abgepasst werden, dass es genau auf dem Mond landet. Und dann kippt's. Und wie sind die dann da hochgekommen? Hochgekraxelt. Bis zum Mond. Hochgekraxelt. Hätte jeder machen können. War auch ein Problem, dass da viel mehr Leute auf die Planke gegangen sind und dann mussten die da wieder runtergebracht werden. Onkel Bernhard nämlich, Onkel Bernhard hat mitgebaut in Rheinhessen an der Planke und der durfte damals mit hochgehen. Bis auf den Mond? Aber er hat irgendwann abgebrochen, weil es ist schon noch ein enormer Marsch. Und das alles kraxelnd. Er ist hochgekraxelnd. Und du hast ja nur vier Minuten, bis der Mond wieder an der falschen Stelle ist. Das Problem ist, dass irgendwann ist der Weg weitergezogen, daran hat man nämlich nicht gedacht. Und dann ist die Planke abgefallen und sie fällt. Und dann ist sie wieder stundenlang gefallen und in der Zeit sind die ja noch hochgekraxelt. Das heißt, die haben zwar in Bezug auf zur Planke Höhe gewonnen, aber da die Planke fällt, sind sie eigentlich eher gesunken, obwohl sie hochgeklettert sind. Das war eine ganz wilde Zeit. Aber bis die Information bei denen ankommt. Wenn Onkel Heinrich die Eure erzählen, wie die Planke hochgeklettert ist, die runtergefallen ist. Das war wild. Das war wirklich wild. Und dann war die zu voll hier auf der Erde, war es dann zu voll mit der Planke, weil man muss sich vorstellen, die ist riesig gross. Ja, wo ist die Planke heute? Da hat man ins Weltall gestossen. Wie hat man die ins Weltall gestossen? Ja, dafür war eine weitere Planke vonnöten. Eine riesige weitere Planke, die noch weiter ist als die zum... Aber es ist die Frage, weil es gibt immer eine grosse Planke. Es gibt immer eine noch grössere Planke irgendwo. Star Wars 1. Es ist im Grunde... Klar, wenn du Plankenbauer bist, siehst du natürlich die Welt durch Planken. Ist ja klar. Da kommst du ja gar nicht gar nicht umhin da komme ich nicht drum herum und du bist in einer plankenfamilie groß geworden ja das merke ich ja das stimmt ja noch weitere fragen was ich will physiker werden nein das wirst du nicht du bist wie dein vater dein grossvater und dein Mein Urgrossvater Plankenbauer. Wie ist unser Nachname? Plank. Ich bin Max Plank. Max, du wirst kein, du wirst kein Planken, äh, ja, hat sich auch auserzählt. So, gute Nacht. Nice, Max Plank. Man muss ja alles erklären können, das ist schon schwierig. Max Planck. Bist du Fan von Max Planck? Geht so, ich habe nur dieses gehört von wegen, ich überlege mir nur immer, weil ich habe keine Ahnung von irgendwas, aber ich überlege mir, wie würde ich ein Referat beginnen. Also egal um welches Thema es geht, ich würde mir immer überlegen, wie würde ich ein Referat anfangen, was dann der Kern oder der Fleischteil des Referats ist, keine Ahnung. Aber ich würde mir überlegen, wie würde ich anfangen. Und bei Max Planck würde ich anfangen mit, ja, herzlich willkommen erst mal, schön, dass ihr da seid. Viele von euch haben ja vielleicht in der Schulzeit noch gar nicht so gewusst, was sie mal machen wollen.
Es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten. Was will ich sein zur feuerwehr will ich etymologe werden oder ja flotten das fünf minuten referatzeit also ich erzähle es nicht ne ich mal zum mond auf dem mond kraxeln was will ich machen und das war der max und der max der wollte unbedingt physiker werden du nur 30 Sekunden? Und dann haben aber alle ihm gesagt, Max, Physik, das ist Quatsch. Physik, das ist schon durch. Man hat alles verstanden. Geh noch zehn? Man hat alles schon irgendwie durch. Alle Bücher wurden geschrieben, da erreichst du nichts mehr. Und der Max hat gesagt, ich werde trotzdem Physiker. Und der hat dann die Quantentheorie entdeckt und das komplette Feld nochmal auf den Kopf gestellt. Super. Dankeschön. Ja, stark. So will ich anfangen. Ja. Ein Bild vom jungen Max Planck, KI generiert. Habe ich, komme ich jetzt nicht dran auf. Schön KI. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das darf, zu sagen, gibt mir ein junges Bild von Stefan Teitz oder so, aber wird sich ja eher alles bahnbrechen. Der hat mir mal eine Idee geklaut, Max Planck. Wirklich? Meine Idee war ja, weil es gibt ja so ein paar Naturkonstanten, wie zum Beispiel Pi. Das ist keine Naturkonstante, aber ich meine, ist so eine Zahl. Das ist schon das erste Beispiel. Nein, nein, nein. Ich meine nicht den interessanten, ich will dich korrigieren, ich meine ist so eine zahl ist schon das erste beispiel ich meine nicht nur das anzen ist ich möchte korrigieren ich meine zahlen die nicht vom die nicht menschen gemacht sind also schon natur gemachte zahlen p ist so eine und die lichtgeschwindigkeit ist so eine es gibt so ein paar konstanten die kommen von der natur uns. Ja. Meine Idee war, das ist die neue Eins. Unsere neue Eins hat einen Wert von zum Beispiel Pi. Aha, also wenn du sagst, um wie viel Uhr fährt der Bus, dann sagst du fünf. Und ich sag, ah, also fünf mal Pi. Fünf Viertel Pi zum Beispiel. Ach so, nee, Moment mal, du sagst dann gar nicht 15 Uhr, du sagst fünf Viertel Pi. Nee, nee, nee, ich will schon, also ich wollte gerne, dass die Lichtgeschwindigkeit zum Beispiel ist 1000. Wir machen so eine neue Fahrenheitsgeschichte. Ach so, du meinst so wie 100 Grad Celsius, bei 100 Grad kochtes Wasser ist ja auch eine Konstante und wenn Null friert. Ja, und wir machen was mit den Naturkonstanten oder Pi. Aber womit genau, also mit welchen Einheiten? Ja, aber das ist ja dann, ich bin ein theoretischer Physiker, ich bin ein Theoretiker. Ja, das sagst du immer, wenn du keine Antwort mehr hast. Ich bin ein Theoretiker. Das sagst du, Max, das sagst du immer, wenn du keine Antwort mehr konkret hast. Ich verstehe dich nicht. Wenn du... Warum nicht? Weil ich in einen anderen Raum gegangen bin. Verstehe ich dich akustisch nicht. Dann komm doch wieder zurück in den Raum, in dem ich bin. Ich habe keine Zeit, die die Welt verändern. Max, ein Objekt kann nicht an zwei Orten gleichzeitig sein. das habe ich dir schon so oft gesagt. Der gleiche Körper kann nicht an zwei Orten gleichzeitig sein, Max. Wenn du in dem einen Raum bist, kannst du in dem anderen nicht sein. Doch. Die Welle-Teilchen-Dualität. So, ähm, na, nee, aber das ist ja hier Quantenphysik.
Ja, okay, ähm, also ich finde das erstmal eine gute Sache, aber ich weiß noch nicht genau, worauf du reifst mit dem Satz, das ist unsere Eins. Ich glaube, wir haben ja manchmal, man ist ja wie zugenagelt.
Manchmal fühlt man sich zugenagelt. Man ist ja wie vernagelt, wie so ein Blackout oder so.
Das ist gerade bei uns so. Ich meine, so Einstein war jetzt auch fast, ist 100 Jahre länger her. Schon länger als 100 Jahre her. Da hat man schon krasse Sachen gewusst. Also langsam denke ich mir, also wo ist der neue heiße Scheiss, ich habe das Gefühl, wir krebsen ein bisschen auf der Stelle rum. Und deswegen habe ich gedacht, wie wäre es denn als Denkhilfe für uns erstmal, wir normen alles, weil wir haben ja die Eins, das kommt ja von uns, das ist ja unser Wert. weisst du das ist pi jetzt so oder sagen, okay, Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist nicht unser Zahlensystem, ist da drin, sondern Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist eine Konstante. Also wenn du sagst, statt hier ist 50er Zone, sagst du hier ist 0,000000000001 Lichtgeschwindigkeitszone. Also sehr schwachenlich sehr schwachen Ländern, wo es sehr, sehr schwierig wird, der Umrechnungskurs. Mhm. So. 0,0000. Okay, ja, finde ich gut. Alles klar. Dann kann man ja runden. Dann kann man ja runden. Oder man sagt, man macht die Nullen weg. Und man sagt immer, die 10 Nullen machen wir eh weg. Oder sowas. Aber dann, ich glaube, das nimmt uns so ein bisschen, es rüttelt uns noch mal so ein bisschen wach. Ja, stimmt. Ich glaube, das ist ein guter Punkt, ja. Ja, und das hat Max Planck gemacht. Basically. Ach, verdammt, ey. Meinst du, der hört den Podcast? Ich habe immer schon das Gefühl, dass manchmal Ideen von grossen Physikern dann auch irgendwie genau nach unserer Folge irgendwie dann kommen oder so. Ist das nicht auch das Gefühl? Ich weiß auch nicht, ob es gemacht hat. Es klang nur so ähnlich und seitdem sage ich das gern. Planckkonstanten oder so. Ich dachte nur, vielleicht nimmt das mal als, ich bin jetzt nicht in der Welt der Physik, ich habe da jetzt nicht so viele Kontakte. In welcher Welt bist du unterwegs? Du bist im Lobster Club? Nehmt's einfach mal mit, ja, ich liebe Lobster. Du bist im Hummer Club? Ich liebe Hummer. Ja, wirklich? Ja. Ich hab in meinem Leben noch nie einen Hummer gegessen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Essen redet ja keiner von. Ach so, so, so, oh, das tut mir leid, das, sorry, dass ich jetzt da voll. Ich lieb die als Tiere. Okay, ja, verstehe ich total. Sie sind clevere Tiere. Okay, alles klar, tut mir leid, tut mir leid, tut mir leid, tut mir leid. Das ist glaube ich das Problem. Tut mir leid, Hummer müssen immer. Aber du hast halt ein Messer auf deinem T-Shirt. Da steht Lobster Club und dann Messer drüber. Das wirkt für mich schon so, als wären die verzehrfertig gemessert. Hör jetzt auf, wir wollen die verteidigen. Ach so, mit dem Messer verteidigen die gegen die Lobsterköche. Wir und die Lobster Hummer haben uns zusammengeschlossen und wollen für die Rechte der Hummer kämpfen. Die sind mehr als nur köstlich. Und die haben diese Scheren. Die sind clever, haben Scheren. Und die sind Muskel und deswegen ist es so geiles Fleisch, oder was? Also die haben... Alles daran ist geil. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich anfangen soll. Es ist so, warum läuft das Wasser im Munster? Alles so lecker. Du meintest doch, du willst sie als Freunde nicht als Essen. Ist auch wahnsinnig lecker, die sind köstlich. Ah ja. Aber die sind auch so viel mehr als das. Du magst sie als Freund und auf dem Teller. Ich finde es nur nicht richtig, dass man die immer reduziert auf Essen. Okay, aber du willst es auch nicht ausschliessen. Es ist für dich beides, Essen und Befreunden. Ja, ich will es nicht, die sind mehr als nur essen und die haben so richtig starke zangen und deswegen ist da so viel fleisch dran dass man die so geil essen kann oder was weil die so stark sind also wer stark ist da hat liefert auch viel gutes fleisch dann einfach aber auch innen drin ist es so lecker aber das das ist wirklich, dann werden die manchmal einfach in kochendes Wasser geschmissen. Das geht ja nicht. Und dann werden die erst rot, oder welche Farbe haben die davor?
Giftegrün.
Weißt du, also die Shrimps sind ja zum Beispiel einfach
ein Weiss, aber wir haben,
also wenn du den Shrimp-Emoji zum Beispiel benutzt,
ist der rot.
Aber die werden ja erst rot durchs Kochen.
Das heisst, das Tier ist ein Ju... jetzt zum Beispiel einfach ein Weiss, aber wir haben, also wenn du den Shrimp-Emoji zum Beispiel benutzt, ist der rot.
Aber die werden ja erst rot durchs
Kochen. Das heißt, das Tier ist
überhaupt nicht rot, sondern die sind halt
einfach nur wie so einen Sonnenbrand kriegen
die dann, wenn die gekocht werden. Das heißt,
das Tier wird bei uns
einfach nur als Nahrungsmittel,
es wird überhaupt nicht als Tier wahrgenommen,
sondern einfach nur, wie sieht's aus
auf dem Teller. Und dann einfach scheißegal, wie das Ding lebt, sondern, ah, das essen wir mit Senfsoße, also es ist gelb einfach so, immer gelb. Muss auf meinem Emoji die Cocktailsoße schon auf mir drauf sein, oder weil... Ja, weil ich bin Huhn und ich weiß, dass Chicken Wings und Barbecue-Sauce gegessen werden, die rotbraun sind, aber ich bin's halt nicht. Und es gibt nicht den Huhn-Emoji, sondern das Chicken-Wing-Emoji.
Ja, genau.
Wir haben verschiedene Emojis, es gibt
den Frosch, es gibt Katze,
es gibt Pferd und es gibt den Chicken-Wing.
Ja, genau, genau, genau, weil ich bin
also, also, Huhn ist ja schon ein
richtig bekanntes Tier. Genau, Chicken-Wing wäre dann dann sozusagen für dich dein,
kannst du dich dann, kannst du dir dann,
kannst du dir nach, unter Nachrichten kannst du dir den Chicken-Wing anpassen. Sie verstehen, warum wir ein bisschen aufgebracht sind, also gut, das ist ein großes Wort, weil sie so köstlich sind.
In erster Linie sind wir wahnsinnig clevere, soziale, spannende, köstliche Tiere, saftig, lecker, knusprige, herrliche, packen sie das Messer weg. Sie haben so schöne Beine. Zwei Beine, zwei Flügel, zwei Flügel. Ich muss husten, Entschuldigung, ich muss während dem Dolchen husten. Le Coquemore, le Coquemore. Le Coquemore. Okay. Der Hahn ist tot. Der Hahn ist köstlich. Le Coquemont. Der Hahn ist wunderköstlich. Aber das ist wirklich wahr, das ist auch sehr, sehr schlimm, dass die in der gekochten Version dann als Emoji gezeigt werden. Ja. Also sie haben halt keine Lobby. Die Shrimps haben keine Stimme.
Also du kannst ja sagen, Katze, Miau, Hund, Wurf, Shrimp, Brutzel, Brutzel.
So Shrimp hat keine Stimme. Null.
Was würdest du sagen, welches Tier hat die beste Lobby?
Süße Tiere eigentlich.
Ja, Hunde glaube ich einfach so. Welche Tiere sind unglaublich köstlich,, aber isst man nicht, weil die zu süss sind. Ah ja, gute Frage. Ich glaube, es ist so wirklich so manche Vögel oder so, ich weiss es nicht, aber es ist und es ändert sich doch schon ein bisschen, was jetzt süss ist und was also so die beliebsten Hunderassen haben sich ja auch verändert im Laufe der Jahre. Das heißt ja, so Tiere wurden wahrscheinlich mal, anders war ich noch mal als jetzt, und der Begriff, die wir nicht so von süss, ändert sich ja auch. Heißt, werden wir irgendwann mal ein Tier essen, was wir jetzt gerade süss finden, was uns jetzt nicht in den kürzesten Träumen einfallen würde, das zu essen. Essen wir mal. Ich glaube, wir werden immer weniger Tiere essen.
Früher wurden auch Katzen gegessen und alles und Pferde auch selbstverständlich, heute weniger.
Ich glaube, es wird sich einfach immer weiter auf das Schwein verengen.
Also ich glaube, irgendwann wird man sagen, das mit den Rindern, das ist nicht so geil.
Und dann irgendwann ist das Schwein einfach das Einzige und das Schwein so,
Leute, es ist auf eine Art schmeichelhaft, aber halt auf eine andere nicht. Und irgendwann isst man kein Hühnchen mehr und alles nur noch auf Schwein.
Ich denke mir in der Zukunft einfach so, man denkt nicht, wenn man reist in die Zukunft und man denkt, krass hier, cool, Autos fliegen durch die Luft. Was machen die da hinten? Werfen die Hamster direkt in die Fritteuse? Werfen die kleine, süße Hamsterchen und Meerschweinchen direkt in die Fritteuse? Und die Zukunft ist so schrei-reif und so Meerschweinchen. Die Hamster werden erst so mit so einem Spiralschnitt so aufgeschnitten und dann so aufgezogen und dann frittiert. Und so kleine, süße Händchen. Genau, dann haben wir so kleine Händchen und dann das Fell wird dann so schön richtig knusprig, kannst du richtig schön mitmachen. Aber ich habe ja letztens entdeckt, ausgestorbene Tiere, das Quagga, Quagga ist nicht mehr, Quagga ist raus und ehrlich gesagt, ist nicht schade drum, weil Quagga ist einfach vorne Zebra, hinten fährt. Ach ja, vorne Zebra, hinten fährt. Es ist einfach, vorne Zebra, hinten Pferd. Es ist einfach straight vorne Zebra, hinten Pferd. Und ich denke mir so, wenn ein Tier ... Fotzehiepfe, vorne hinten, vorne Zebra, hinten Pferden. Fotzehiepfe, ich sage mal so, wenn ein Tier ausstirbt, wenn ein Tier ausstirbt von allen Tieren, dann doch bitte das, was offensichtlich ein Mischtier von zwei ohnehin existierenden Tieren ist.
Weil wir haben noch Zebras, wir haben noch Pferde, braucht doch nicht unbedingt einen Quaggar.
Aber warum kam das dann dabei raus? Das ist ja unglaublich lustig, das Quaggar.
Quaggar ist, es sollte nichts gegen Quaggar, ich meine, es ist ausgestorben, wir werden keine Leserberichte kriegen.
Aber Quaggar ist richtig dumm.
Fortpflanzung würde ganz anders funktionieren und Evolution.
Doch, du hast immer Männchen vorne, Weibchen hinten. Du hast immer Zebra vorne, also das ist Mutter. Unabhängig vom Zebra hat man immer Zebra vorne. Es ist umgekehrt alphabetisch. Also das Z-Tier ist vorne, das P-Tier ist hin. Ich verstehe es nicht, weil Hunderassen sehen ja alle anders aus.
Ja.
Und die sind nicht vorne im Kockerspanel, hinten Schäferhund.
Ja, das stimmt, aber bei so Pferdedingern ist es einfach ... Bei so Pferdedingern.
Sorry.
Ich soll jetzt gar nicht abwertend klingen, aber es gibt manche ausgestorbene Tiere, wo man wirklich sagt, oh nein, muss das wirklich sein, tut mir leid, aber beim Quagger, boah, zum Beispiel der kleine Pampashase, auch ausgestorben, er ist gar nicht ausgestorben, lebt noch, gibt's noch ein paar. Boah, pass auf ein bisschen, pass auf, was du hier raus haust, ey. Noch nicht ausgestorben. Tiere als ausgestorben, wird die Kinn. Noch nicht ausgestorben, aber das Geile ist ja, das Quagger ist ein aus ausgestorbenes Tier vorne Zebrahänden Pferd, von dem es nur Schwarz-Weiss-Bilder gibt. Weil es ist schon so lange ausgestorben, dass es kein Farbbild von dem Zebra-Pferde-Tier gibt. Das heißt, es ist immer Schwarz-Weiss. Der Zebra-Teil hat gewonnen! Der Zebra-Teil hat gewonnen! Das Tier sieht einfach mehr aus wie ein Zebra als ein Pferd.
Aber es gibt dieses Bild, diese Malerei.
Es gibt die Malerei, richtig, ja. Aber da muss man natürlich auch gucken.
Auf der Malerei ist der Zebrateil Pferdefarben.
Das ist übrigens, da sehen wir jetzt ein ganz interessantes biologisches Phänomen, denn hier dieses Gemäldequagger hat oben schwarz, unten weiss. Warum? Also der Rücken ist schwarz, der Bauch ist weiss. Warum? Naja, nicht schwarz, es ist so dunkelbraunes Pferdefarbe. Aber unten ja auch nicht, und Zebra sind ja nicht weiss, sondern gestreift. Gibt es aber bei ganz vielen Tieren, bei vielen Fischen zum Beispiel, ist der Rücken dunkler als der Bauch. Das verstehe ich, weil wenn man von oben drauf guckt, ist scheißegal, und von unten sollen sie aussehen wie der Himmel. Nee, von oben sollen sie aussehen wie der Boden.
Von unten sollen sie aussehen wie der Himmel, damit der Hai denkt, ach ja, schöner Tag heute. Nee, einfach damit sie sich der Umgebung angepasst sind. Nee, es hat was damit zu tun. Flundern zum Beispiel sehen ja oben aus wie ein Steinboden und von unten wie ein Himmel. Der Effekt ist, dass wenn normalerweise scheint ja die Sonne von oben drauf und dann wird der obere Teil hell und der untere Teil ist schattig. Und wenn das Fell jetzt aber so gefleckt ist, dass es oben dunkle und unten weiss ist, wird dieser Effekt rausgecancelt und damit ist das Tier getarnt. Normalerweise, wenn du so rauf guckst in die Savanne und dann siehst du, dass irgendwo so Schattenbauch und oben hell ist, weißt du, da ist ein Tier, aber wenn es das ausgleicht mit dem Fell, dann nicht. Ist ein Tarnungseffekt, hat dem Quagger aber offensichtlich auch nicht geholfen, der ist tot. Wollen wir hier einen Quagger an, also ein Pferd anmalen? Hä? Komm mal, komm mal kurz näher, komm mal kurz näher. Ich höre dich, ich höre dich, ich höre dich, verstärkt durch Technik. Wollen wir ein Pferd anmalen? Und dann sagen, wir haben noch ein Quagga gefunden, ein Fake-Lazarus-Effekt sozusagen, der auf unsere Kappe geht. Ja, unsere Quagga-Kappa. Auf unsere Quagga-Kappa. Man kann das natürlich mit Kappa auch noch. Das war gar kein Quagga Kappa. So, wir haben...
Wait, wait, das war gar kein Kappa und kein, kürzen sich raus, einem Sinn, es war ein Quagga. Was wir gefunden haben, ist ein Quagga Kappa. Ah, Kappa. Und dann sagen wir, ah, das ist eigentlich nur ironisch, eigentlich nicht dabei, ja, finde ich. Wir malen es an, wir malen es an, dann stellen wir es aus. Können wir auch machen. Im Pukasufo-Zoo, weil ich sehe hier gerade, das letzte Stab im Zoo Amsterdam, da waren bestimmt viele da. Als es gestorben ist mein Zoo? Dann haben Rosen niedergelegt und sowas. Wenn sie es gesehen haben. Wenn sie es denn gesehen haben. Es war so gut, weil es ist zu gut getarnt, dass es keine Fortpflanzungspartner gefunden hat. Es ist vorne getarnt und hinten nicht. Ja, das stimmt. Es sieht aus wie ein halbes Pferd. Ja, und der Löwe denkt sich, was soll ich denn das jetzt da reissen? Das ist ein halbes Pferd. Eine halbe Portion. Was soll ich jetzt da mitmachen? Das ist eine halbe Portion. Das brauche ich nicht. Das ist ja viel schneller. Wenn das zwar fürs hat, dann rennt es davon. Rennst davon? Ich kann es nicht. Ich kann's nicht. All den Jahren. Quagga. Quagga. Ja, ich bin dafür, es anzumalen. Wir hoffen, es regnet nicht. Und dann laufen wir dem Geld weg. In Taschen. Man muss ja schon sagen, ne? Nur Bar. Nur Bargeld, sagen wir dann. Der Mensch hat ja schon, also jetzt mal, wir sind ja jetzt in der Biologie-Ecke, da kann man auch über sowas reden, der Mensch hat schon einen mächtigen Anus. Wieso? Weil wenn du dir jetzt überlegst, du bist ein Pferd, dann ist ja alles, hängt ja runter in den Bauch und da ist zu. Wohingegen da fällt ja nichts einfach hinten raus. Der Mensch hingegen läuft aufrecht, das heißt alles will eigentlich raus unten und dadurch muss ständig der Schliessmuskel eigentlich zuhalten, wie bei so einem Luftballon, wo du die ganze Zeit zuhalten musst, muss der ja eigentlich stark entwickelt sein, anders als bei Kühen oder Pferden, wo es einfach rauslaufen kann, wo es einfach da nicht so stark gebraucht wird, weil es wird ja gar nicht aus, das heißt, du würdest ein Pferd schnell drehen, so dass die Zentrifugalkräfte Aber die sind Scheinkraft. Du, der Scheiss Scheinkraft, hat trotzdem Effekt. Zentripitalkraft. Och nee, nee, da mache ich nicht mit bei dem Scheiss. Das heißt, ich weiß, und ich weiß sogar, dass es eigentlich Zentripetalkraft heißt, ich sag trotzdem Zentrifugalkraft, weil das einfach so verwendet wird. Weil die Leute das falsch verwenden, also verwendet ich es auch falsch. Ich will nur, dass du in den Knast kommst. Man wird heutzutage nicht mehr in den Knast bekommen, weil man Scheinkräfte als echte Kräfte bezeichnet, okay? Diese Gesetzeslage, ich war so lange genug eingefroren, dass das keine Straftat mehr ist, und kann ich es auch sagen. So, ich dachte gerade über etwas anderes, wir haben mächtige Anus im Sinne von, wir haben riesengroße schicke Ärsche. Und ich gucke die ganze Zeit auf diese wunderschönen Zebra-Hintern und denke mir, da können wir nicht mithalten. Da können wir wirklich nicht mithalten. Weil ich muss sagen, Pferde haben schon, muss man, also ich verstehe nicht, warum alle mit dem Berghalten mit, fantastische Hintern haben. Pferde haben richtig geile Hintern. Weil der Mensch hat ja einen 180 Grad Hintern, ein Pferd hat ja einen 270 Grad, weil es ja aus der Senkrechten den Dreiviertelkreis macht, bei Menschen ja nur einen Halbkreis. Das heißt, es ist nicht nur mehr da, sondern was da ist, ist auch besser. Ja und die haben halt diese muskulösen Beine auch, also das ist schon nicht schlecht. Es ist ein erotisches Tier. Ich meine, wir haben alle in der Schule den Schimmelreiter gelesen, da wird natürlich auch angespielt auf die Erotik des Reitens, na klar. Was haben wir gelesen? Den Schimmelreiter. Ja genau. Ich erinnere mich sogar noch explizit an meine... Erzähl trotzdem noch mal, was es ist. Ich erinnere mich tatsächlich explizit noch an meine Deutschlehrerin, die irgendwie siebte, achte Klasse oder so an der Tafel, dann Schimmelreiter, wurde dann irgendwie so eine Szene analysiert und dann so mit, ja, die starken Lenden und die Klasse so hiiii, ja und der kräftige Leib jetzt... Weil die immer gelacht hat, weil die nicht kennt oder was? Ja, weil die Metapher ein bisschen unsauber ist, deswegen haben wir gekichert. Und dann so der mächtige Leib zwischen den Schenkeln, alle so hihihihi. Und irgendwann dreht sich die Lehrerin um. Ja, das ist durchaus auch als sexuelle Anspielung gemeint. Also wirklich so, ihr seid jetzt nicht super schlau, dass ihr hier lacht. Das ist die Idee der Szene. Wir können, das ist, darum geht's hier gerade, das ist kein verstecktes und alles so. Ach so, ach gut. Ja, dann lass uns doch nochmal über die Schenkel reden. Mehr über Schenkel reden. Das war tatsächlich ein Moment des Erwachsenwerdens, wo es hieß, Sex und Erotik ist kein Kicherthema, sondern darum geht's hier eins zu eins. Das ist kein verstecktes Hihihihi, sondern das ist Thema gerade. Ja, finde ich super spannend. Und das war wirklich im Moment, ab dem Punkt habe ich nie wieder gekichert über irgendwie Hihihi und Ansprüche. Seitdem glaube ich nicht mehr gekichert. Nie wieder gekichert. Gelacht ja, gelachen ja, schallend, aber gekichert nicht. Aber gekichert nicht. Erwachsen geworden. Gekichert, da bin ich in dem Moment erwachsen geworden, weil ich mir dachte, ah okay, das ist jetzt kein Kicherthema mehr, sondern einfach, das ist jetzt auf dem Lehrplan. Heißt der Typ mit dem Gedicht Stand auf die Pferde hintern? Na gut, jetzt machst du natürlich wieder auf, weil die Figuren das so wahrnehmen muss, der Autor das auch, also da dachte ich eigentlich, dass du da weiter bist. Ich meine nur, kann man da mal fragen, jetzt mal einfach mal fragen. Theodor Storm, ne? Hast du gegoogelt, ne? Scheiße, mittlerweile kann man das nicht mehr verstecken, einfach. Verdammtes Patreon einfach, alle kriegen mit, wie wir einfach jeden Scheiß googeln müssen, wie die letzten Trottel. Weil ich habe in der Schule halt zu viel gekichert und nicht aufgepasst.
Ja, finde ich, ja, muss ich sagen.
Ist ja eine Novelle, ne? Die Novelle.
Ja, liest doch mal einfach auf von Wikipedia, was alles noch so ist mit Theodor Storm.
Was hat er noch so gemacht?
Übrigens fantastischer Name.
1984, Theodor Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm, Storm. Okay, Flotin, das Refer referat die referatzeit ist vorbei storm wie
würde ich ein gedicht wie würde ich ein referat zu theodor storm begreifen storm storm mein storm
mein storm storm storm storm ja okay so ging ja eigentlich um den reiter storm ja storm storm Mein Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sturm, Sprache, was löst geschriebene Sprache in uns auf?
Okay, alles klar, wir sind jetzt zu Ende.
Nee, du hast ja kein Referat gehalten.
Ja doch, es ist eine Impression von Sprache, was sie bedeutet. Deutschunterricht, ich meine, ich kenne. Das war durchaus auch als sexuelle Anspielung gedacht, Frau Riedlinger. Ach so, dann entschuldige mich fürs Kichern. Das ist aber super spannend, wie man dann in so einer Klasse einfach den Teppich unter den Füssen wegzieht. Komplett den Teppich unter der Pubertät
wegzieht einfach. Komplett
Pubertät im Freiflug. Ah, man kann darüber
lachen, das ist auch durchaus so gemeint.
Wir können auch gemeinsam lachen. Genau.
Das ist gar nicht vorgehaltenes Handlachen.
Das ist aber spannend, weil an irgendeinem Punkt
wächst man auch gewisserweise mit den Lehrern so ein bisschen zusammen.
Es gibt ja diesen Verbrüder im Moment irgendwann,
hatte ich zumindest das Gefühl, auch wenn die Lehrer vielleicht jünger
werden oder sowas, wir hatten ein paar jüngere Lehrer, die so als Referendare dann irgendwann LKs übernommen haben.
das war schon irgendwie eine Zeit, wo man dann auch ja wahrscheinlich auch spannender wird für Lehrer, weil die
die können mit denen reden und man kann wirklich irgendwie vielleicht auch so coole Sachen
mit den Klassen machen und da gibt es schon diesen verbrüdernden Moment, wo man nicht
mehr dieses jemand steht vorne und die Klasse sagt, macht dich lustig und hat
so Spucke. vielleicht auch so coole Sachen mit den Klassen machen. Und da gibt es schon diesen verbrüdernden Moment, wo man nicht mehr dieses, jemand steht vorne und die Klasse sagt,
macht dich lustig und hat so Spucke, Strohhalme.
Und irgendwann kippt es dann und man lacht vielleicht einfach zusammen
über die, ja, ironischen Zusammenhänge in der Geschichte.
In der Schimmelreiter von Theodor.
Beim Schimmelreiter.
Storm, Storm.
Viel im Deich, ne, also viel aus der norddeutsche Deich-Literatur. Deiche, Wasser. Ist das was, womit du was anfangen kannst? Ja, ich war jetzt neulich in Hamburg, habe hier Besuch, wir haben da Improv gemacht. Du bist nass geworden. Ich mag das sehr, dieses ganze Nautische in Hamburg, kann ich sehr viel mit anfangen. Es ist ein bisschen alles ist so feucht, alles ist so ein bisschen marode, viel Holz, altes Holz. Ich mag das ganz gerne, urigen Kneipen mit Bier. Dann war ich Essen im Erikas Eck. Eine uralte Kult-Kneipe, Schnitzelladen, voll, es war mega Schnitzel, und dann kriegt man da so einen Riesen, Riesenhumpen Bier hingestellt. Und es fühlt sich an wie so eine Hafenkneipe. Was ja eine richtige Kajüte ist. Ja, und das fand ich dann schon ganz cool. Aber ich erinnere mich auch, Hesel Brugger hat mal gesagt, dass sie das nicht so mag, dieses nautische, bisschen roughe, maritime. Aber das ist ja kein Schlimmes. Also du kommst ja trotzdem noch gut durchs Leben, wenn du jetzt mit dem nautischen nicht so viel anfangen kannst. In Hamburg nein. In Hamburg? Naja. Gut, dann darfst du nicht in Hamburg leben. Aber es ist jetzt, glaube ich, nicht das Schlimmste, was man als Ablehnung haben kann. Dann ist Hamburg nichts für dich. Ich kann sogar tatsächlich von meinem Arbeitsplatz aus die Schiffe tröten hören. Und das ist immer wieder so ein Weckruf. Es gibt eine Welt da draußen. Irgendjemand fährt jetzt irgendein Schiff irgendwo hin durchs Wasser, das Wasser wird verdrängt, fliesst als Welle an den Strand, wo jemand sitzt, auf das Schiff schaut, sitzt er mit seinem Picknick-Core und masturbiert zum Schiff.
Weil Schiffe haben auch richtig geile Ärsche manchmal. Es war durchaus auch oft so kichern, es war auch sexuell gemeint, weil ich finde die geil. Ja, okay. Also es gibt ja auch Objekte, also da gibt es ja auch attraktive, was würdest du sagen von dem klassischen Haushaltsgerät? Spannend. Welches ist das erotischste? Haushaltsgeräte? Ja, mach mal jetzt mal nur Haushaltsgeräte, damit es mal so ein bisschen übersichtlich wird. Aber wir machen jetzt nicht mal so, wir machen jetzt nicht irgendwie, weiss ich nicht, Womanizer. Lockstab oder so. Wir machen jetzt nicht mal so Sexspielzeug, machen wir jetzt nicht. Nee, nee, einfach nur von der Form her. Oder von der Funktion, von der Energie her am erotischsten. So der Toaster, den du so reindrückst und dann springt der so raus irgendwann. Oder so dieser klobige Kühlschrank einfach so. Föhn. Ja, mit dieser heißen Luft. Und es sind nicht so Lippen, die so offen sind. Die so anhauchen. Ja, genau. Es ist nicht so ein offener Mund, der sich anhaucht. Ein schönes Föhndesign eigentlich, so ein Kopf, wo jemand so ... So kleine zusammen drückte Augen.
Hauchen ist auch so was Merkwürdiges.
Es ist so, wann hauchst du?
Wann man haucht?
Wann hauchst du?
Er hat noch nie eine Brille getragen.
Ja, okay, das stimmt.
Brille natürlich.
Ich habe tatsächlich kleine Live-Fun-Hack, nenne ich die mittlerweile. Falsch einfach. Nee, es ist eine Art Fun-Fact, aber es ist auch ein Live-Hack. Es ist ein Fun-Hack, ein Hack, der auch Spaß macht. Und zwar mache ich immer, wenn ich Dosen trinke, ich trinke recht viel Dosen. Und zwar bei Dosen ist immer so, man weiss ja, die lagern, wo lagern die, wie viele Ratten haben, welche Körpersäfte, wie, in welcher Nähe, in welcher Distanz, in welchem Sprühwinkel, genau wo. Mit was für dicken Penis, in welchen dicken, wie, semi-irrigiert, vollirrigiert, gar nicht. Also wie genau läuft das ab? Und dann weiss man aber nicht und dann denkt man so, soll ich da jetzt wirklich meine feuchten, weichen Lippen draufpressen oder nicht? Ich habe den Anfang vergessen. Was hast du? Ich verstehe. Ich kann dir nicht folgen. Du hast dich verfangen in Rattenpimmeln.
Eine Dose trinke. Soll ich meine
weichen, pulsierenden,
warmen Lippen auf das
kalte Metall pressen oder
nicht und dann denke ich mir,
ich mach die sauber,
und zwar hauche ich die Dose
oben an und
wisch die dann ab mit dem Taschentuch oder mit meinem T-Shirt und dann trinke ich sie.
Das ist mein Fun-Hack.
Warum pustest du nicht?
Weil Pusten nicht genug Feuchtigkeit hat. Hauchen haut richtig die Feuchtigkeit raus und dann hast du so ein bisschen Kondensspucke und dann kannst du schön abwischen und fertig.
Dann musst du nicht mit Wasser hantieren.
Mach doch ein Glas rein.
Habe ich jetzt einen wunden Punkt troffen? Mach doch die Dose in ein Glas rein. Stefan, ich möchte jetzt hier abbrechen. Warum? Ich möchte jetzt hier abbrechen. Du hast das Problem nicht verstanden. Wofür ist die Dose denn da? Du trinkst ja nicht aus einer Dose und dann kannst du dich einfach sagen, dass du hier ins Glas schenken. Wie unsinnig kann man denn sein? Du kannst jetzt nicht die Folge abbrechen. Willst du die Folge abbrechen jetzt? Ich glaube, ich muss die abbrechen. Du bist einfach ein unsensibler Gesprächspartner. Wenn ich dich frage, soll ich über die A1, über die A3 fahren und du sagst, nimm nur einen Zug. Stefan, darum geht's nicht. Ja, vielleicht geht's darum nicht, aber es wäre jetzt die bessere Alternative. Ja, aber es geht auch darum, das Problem zu lösen. Es ist ein Fun-Hack. Es ist ein Fun-Hack. Okay, es soll auch Spaß machen. Du bist immer so ernst, wenn man denn Fun-Hacks. Ja, weil es um Spaß geht, aber auch um Hacks. Okay, es ist nicht nur ein Hack, es ist auch Fun. Und du verstehst den Fun-Aspekt nicht.
Du verstehst nicht, was daran Fun ist.
Dass ein Comedian so sauer wird, auf der Bühne
bin ich auch immer so lustig. Warum lacht
ihr darüber jetzt nicht? Das ist auch
Fun. Ich hab so extra Fun gemacht.
Ich hab so extra lustig gesagt.
Ja gut, dann
brechen wir, würde ich sagen, jetzt hier einfach ab.
Ja. Ich hab da nichts mehr zu sagen. Was nützt es mir noch, mit dir zu reden, wenn du so wenig Empathie hast, dass du dich irgendwie in mein Problem, in mein Life reinversetzen kannst? Nein, ich meine nur, um weiter zu gehen, um weiter zu kommen und ein bisschen Tempo zu machen, würde ich sagen, wäre es nicht auch eine Idee. Nein, aber das ist immer was anderes.
Ja, klar, das ist was anderes.
Das ist wie wenn ich dir von meinem Job erzähle,
dass ich auch manchmal Stress habe,
weil es auch wirklich viel Druck ist,
und du sagst, ja, dann wäre doch Lamellentester.
Warum geht es doch gerade nicht?
Kannst du nicht immer sagen, ja, dann mach doch Lamellen.
Legionellen.
Äh, Legionellentester.
Guck mal, du hast mich wahnsinnig mit deinem Quatsch jedes Mal.
So, ich brech jetzt hier ab.
Nee, weil du hast ein bisschen zu viel Stress, glaube ich.
Nein, ich brech jetzt hier ab, ich brech jetzt die Folge ab.
Du kannst jetzt nicht abbrechen.
Ich brech die Folge hier ab.
Stopp, ich brech ab.
Abbruch, Abbruch.